[Narrator] The answer is 5.
Let's step through each statement to see why.
The first statement creates a new list.
It's elements are 1 and 2, and makes the variable P refer to that list.
The next statement evokes append on P, passing in the value 3.
Append adds an element to the end of the list,
so after this the value that P refers to will include 1 extra element with the value 3.
The next statement uses the plus operator.
The operands to the plus are P, which we already have,
and the new list containing the elements 4 and 5,
and remember what happens with plus; it doesn't mutate any of the inputs.
It creates a new list that consists of all the elements concatenated together.
That will be this 5-element list.
We assign that to the variable P, so now P will no longer refer to the list 1, 2, 3.
It will refer to this new list that has 5 elements,
and at the end of this, the len of P is 5, since there are 5 elements in P.